Wow, what a powerful morning already hasn't it?
Uh, don't worry.
We'll get to thing some more a little bit later,
so we'll get there, uh, in a few minutes.
But if you're new to our church, we're
so thankful you'd be here.
Welcome. Uh, we know it's a big deal
and so we're always blessed when you
and others like you would be here just to show up.
We would love to meet you.
If you haven't already filled out the QR code in front
of you or the new here area in the lobby,
please just introduce yourself.
We'd love to tell you a little bit about who we are,
help you connect to Jesus and to us.
Now, while we do hope today is a unique encouragement
as many of you're dressed up a little
uniquely and things like that.
It's not a special day, but,
but the reality is it's not really any different than any
other Sunday, and that's on purpose
because our faith is in Christ alone every single day,
not just on an emotional high Sunday like an Easter would be
because our hope is in who he is
and what he's done for us,
and that in his death to life experience, he has the power
to bring us from death to life as well.
Now, here's the reality though.
I acknowledge that some of you in this room don't believe
that and you're just here
because your family dragged you here
so they can get a good picture for the gram, right?
Like that's what they want to do,
and you're just here, okay?
I get it. I'm glad you're here.
And you may not believe
because you just can't conceive the fact
that someone could actually come back to life that just,
it's impossible to you.
I would encourage you just to be curious about that
and, and do some research.
Look into it and see just what God would do
to teach you something there or,
or maybe, maybe you don't believe
because there's, you just feel like there's no way
God could save you.
You've gone too far, you've done too much and,
and you feel like it's, it's a, a no hope situation for you
and that's why you don't believe.
Listen, I've been there before.
I've thought that in my own life at some point,
so that's maybe some of you.
But I also know there's another group here today.
This may be you that you do believe,
but you just get regularly sucked into that vortex
of temptation And you just feel like this cycle
of sin that you're living in just makes you frustrated.
Your life is unsatisfying because of that and you,
and you're quietly concerned about your actual relationship
with God that you, you've kind of been feeling
that maybe his love is conditional and you've gone too far.
And listen, the enemy
of our souls would love nothing more than to keep you in
that place, to keep you in that state,
and that's all you feel and you are trapped.
That's why today again, we're gonna focus on
what Christ has done, believing
that his resurrection power can bring you
and me from death to life as well.
So let's just start by praying for a moment.
I want you to just, to quiet your heart in preparation
for God's word, what he wants to say to you and to me today.
Maybe you don't believe, maybe this is a struggle for you
and just, just be honest with God,
just a maybe you've never prayed before.
And just a, a simple cry.
God, speak to me today
and see what he does for all of us.
Ask God to root these truths deep in our hearts.
Lord, we do pray that as your word is opened
and studied today, that we would respond
and hear what you want us to hear.
Speak to us through
what you've already said here in Jesus' name.
Amen. Now we're gonna end up in Romans
chapter six today.
So you can go ahead and take your copy of God's Word, turn
with me there on your device maybe as well
or underneath the seat in front of you.
There could be one Bible if you brought forgot yours,
that's fine, Roman six.
But it, it's hard to just kind of parachute into the middle
of a book without the context of everything around it.
So I wanna just give you a quick overview of the book
of Romans and really what we're gonna see throughout
this quick overview,
but then even into the passage we'll study is the truth
of God, the truth of us, and the truth of salvation.
The truth about God, the truth about us,
the truth about salvation
because the book of Romans is a rich,
comprehensive explanation of the gospel.
It teaches us everything we need to know about this gospel.
And so here's how the apostle Paul who inspired by God
to write this, here's how he started it.
He began by spending a long time highlighting the nature
of our sin.
That our sin is not merely like missing the mark
or just kind of falling it.
It's actually at its root rebellion against God.
And that sin then,
because that's what it is, causes physical
and spiritual death in every one of us.
That's the roots, the nature of sin that we're all guilty
of needing that righteousness that it takes
to get to be with God.
We're all guilty of needing it,
but being unable to provide it ourselves.
It's very clear in Romans,
but he didn't stop there thankfully.
He continued by saying, yes, we need that righteousness,
but God himself
provided that righteousness, not by our own works, not
because we deserved it or earned it, it's
because of his grace of Jesus living
a perfect life in our place.
We couldn't do it. We needed to. We couldn't.
Jesus did it for us.
And again, that's his grace, a gift.
This is what Ephesians two says about that.
By grace, you have been saved through faith.
This is not your own doing.
It is the gift of God, not a result of works
so that no one may boast.
He gives that gift of Jesus perfect life,
death and resurrection for you.
That's a grace to us.
And listen, that's, he did that in spite of the fact
that every single one of us falls short
of God's perfect standard and we don't deserve it.
Just like you don't deserve birthday gifts,
but you get, you receive them, right?
God gave a gift
even though we don't deserve it.
And in spite of the fact, listen,
not only that, we don't deserve it.
He gave it to us.
Knowing that we continue to fall short
of his perfect standard from that point forward,
that's just abundant amazing grace.
So again, maybe you walked in here feeling
like you're too far gone.
One of the main truths that Romans teaches us is this,
you cannot outs sin God's grace.
Like you can't outs send it.
His grace abounds,
his grace covers you can't outs sin His grace.
You can't go too far, have gone too far in that
because if it's not based on you to begin with,
if it's a gift of God's grace to you,
then you haven't gone too far.
It's not based on you.
You haven't gone too far
because one John one, nine says, if we confess our sins,
he's faithful and just to forgive us our sins
and to cleanse us from all unrighteousness,
not some sins, not the ones that aren't too bad all sins,
no qualification, confess, he forgives.
And so that's the truth. You can't outs send God's grace.
But here's then the question that could come up
in light of that truth, what's
the question that could arise?
And we'll see it here in Romans chapter six.
Look at verse one. Here's the
question, what shall we say then?
Are we to continue in sin
that Grace May abound, right?
You see the question that could result from
that whole tree can't outs send grace.
And so the the logic of it seems to think like this.
So if if God's grace Is
covering my sin and that that's good, right?
Grace is good. So I'm sin grace covers sin.
The more sin grace abounds over that if, if that's the truth
and I want more grace, should I then sin
more to get more grace?
Like that's the question, should I sin more?
Because grace abounds where sin abounds.
I I want more grace, so I should sin more right now.
I know, I know. Kids are like, what are you saying?
No, right? That it's a, it sounds really weird
to our modern ears.
We know the Sunday school answer to this.
But listen, the enemy loves
To take anything
And twist it to trip you up.
And so this seems illogical to us, but,
but it actually is something people wrestle with.
And So what's the answer to it?
I think we all know, right? Should we
send more to receive more grace?
Well look at the first couple words of verse two.
By no means that's all he says, by no means, right?
That's the, in the original language, that is the strongest
possible way to say no meaning,
absolutely, positively, definitely not.
Should you send more to get more grace.
It just does not work that way.
That's not how this thing works. You shouldn't,
well, thankfully Paul gave us reasons
Why.
Okay, so that's not the right answer.
We're not question right, not the right question to ask.
So what do we do? Well,
what is the reason why we shouldn't do that?
I wanna read the whole passage now, Romans six, one
through 11, and I want you
to see if you can pick out the reasons that God gives us.
What shall we say then?
Are we to continuing sin that Grace May abound By no means,
how can we who died to sin still live in it?
Do you not know that all of us
who have been baptized into Christ Jesus were
baptized into his death?
We were buried, therefore with him
by baptism into death in order that just
as Christ was raised from the dead, by the glory
of the Father, we too might walk in newness of life
for if we've been united with him in a death like his,
we shall certainly be united
with him in a resurrection like his.
We know that our old self was crucified with him in order
that the body of sin might be brought to nothing so
that we would no longer be enslaved to sin
for one who's died, has been set free from sin.
Now, if we've died with Christ,
we believe we'll also live with him.
And we know that Christ being raised from the dead,
we'll never die again.
Death no longer has dominion over him for the death he died.
He died to sin once for all.
But the life he lives, he lives to God.
So you also must consider yourselves dead to sin
and alive to God in Christ Jesus.
So you saw his logical argument, right?
Here's the truth, here's what this means.
Here's what this he, he walks through it
and really it, it comes into two big buckets of how he said,
here's the reason you shouldn't send more to get more grace.
Let me show you. Here's the first reason.
It's because Christ actually brought sin to nothing.
The first reason is because Christ brought sin to nothing.
That's what verse six says.
We know our old self was crucified with him in order
that the body of sin might be brought to nothing so
that we would no longer be enslaved to sin.
And so this is what we just celebrated a couple days ago on
Good Friday when Jesus died, when the perfect Christ
died on that cross in our place, it was to destroy the power
of sin and to
free us from the power of sin.
That's why his death was so good, why it matters.
When he took the death that we deserved on that cross,
he did it so that we wouldn't have
to receive the punishment for our sin anymore.
Death he took that away.
And so he destroyed sin and its power,
and he did that so that we would have the sins grip
released from our lives.
The chains would be broken.
See, here's the reality, whether you realize it
or not, every single one of us, every human
apart from God on our own, every one
of us are enslaved to sin.
We're born into it. We sin, we, we are enslaved to it
until God does something different.
I've heard people say, I've had conversations
with people all over the world.
I've heard people say about Christianity.
They're like, ah, man, it's, it's oppressive.
Like how do you guys, you guys, all those rules, like
that's just so oppressive.
I, I wanna live my life the way I wanna live it.
I'm, I don't wanna be free. I don't shackled up by that.
I wanna be free. Here's how I respond.
You actually aren't free.
Even if you think that you're in charge,
you're running the show, you're on your own.
You actually aren't free. You are a slave to sin.
It is what controls you. It pulls the strength.
It's telling you what to do and what not to do.
You're not in control as much as you think you are.
That's the reality for every one of us apart from Christ.
Yet what Christ has done is
what frees us from that slavery.
Look at verse seven, for one who has died
has been set free from sin,
not a slave anymore.
Free from it because Christ died.
You have now been freed as well.
But the only way you get that is by identifying
with Christ in his death.
You don't have to die anymore because he died for you.
But you have to identify,
that's the baptism language here that he talks about.
That you've, by faith, you've not done the act,
but you've thought by faith
that Christ's death counts for yours.
You've said, I'm in, all my eggs are in that basket.
I am hopeless without him, his death counts for mine.
And if he died, then by identification I say, I died too.
I am in him. So I have died, which is
how Paul can say in verse two, how can those who've died
to sin still live in it?
He died. You died to sin.
How can you still live in it?
It's a logical impossibility at that point
because again, Christ's death means believers are free now.
So Christ brought sin to nothing, but there's more.
Christ also brought death to nothing.
He brought death to its knees.
That's really the central point of
what we're celebrating today on
this resurrection day, right?
The fact that Christ came out of the grave, it's
what verse nine says here, we know
that Christ being raised from the dead will never die again.
Death no longer has dominion over him.
No longer says here's how this is gonna go,
has has any sway over him.
He is not under its authority,
which again means then let's go back to identification
for those who are in Christ.
By faith, death no longer has dominion over us either.
If he died and we identify with his death, if he raised,
we identify with his resurrection.
That's what verse five says.
If we've been united with him in a death like his,
we shall certainly be united
with him in a resurrection like his.
It counts for us.
That means that death is not the final word for us either.
We can walk as verse four said in newness of life.
Now, just because he raised from the dead,
it's counted for us.
Verse eight, if we've died with Christ,
we believe we'll also live with him.
This is a guarantee
that when Christ came outta the grave alive,
that's a guarantee that we're gonna come outta the
grave alive someday as well.
Death used to be
before 2000 years ago, an undefeated enemy
death is no longer undefeated.
Christ has defeated death forever.
But then what does that mean for us today?
So, so what does all this, like what are the results?
Then let, let's make this personal.
There's a lot of good theory and
and we worship Christ for this,
but what are the results in our day-to-day lives
of what Jesus has done?
Well, let me give you one here.
If you are a believer,
if you've believed in him, then
because Jesus brought sin to nothing
and he brought death to nothing.
If you're a believer that now means you have a new identity,
you are a new person, you have a new
identity, watch this.
Look again at the end of this section, verse 11, notice
how he closed this section out.
So as a result of all that, you also must
consider yourselves dead to sin
and alive to God in Christ
Jesus Like this.
This is what he's saying here, consider yourself that word.
Consider means to calculate and then to believe.
Like you go through a logical process
of figuring something out.
You've searched all the answers, you've come
to this conclusion.
That's the result, and you're holding onto that.
That's that word. Consider
yourself what?
That because Christ died because Christ is alive to God.
I can now consider myself dead to sin
and alive to God in Christ.
That is your new identity.
Now, like you are under new ownership, used to be enslaved
to sin, now you're free.
That that sign on the side
of the building has changed right under new ownership.
That's you. Consider yourself that.
Keep telling yourself that over and over.
Keep pounding that into your brain, into your heart,
that you're not defined.
Hear this, you're not defined by that sin anymore.
You're not defined by your past anymore.
If this is true, you are defined by Christ
and what he has done for you.
It's his work in your place. It's not your work.
And listen, when you understand that, when
that gets deep into your soul
and you stand on that solidly, man,
that's a freeing place to be, isn't it?
My identity is not in what people think about me
or say about me or what I did in the past.
My identity is now only in Christ alone.
And what he says I am
and who he says I am, like that's freeing.
That's how you can live a life to God now instead
of enslaved to your past.
And so again, that's true for you, possible for you.
Whether you've run hard away from God your whole life
or whether you grew up in the church
and your whole life has been this moral mask
and you didn't believe, if
Christ is who you're believing in, your
identity is in him.
This is your new identity.
If you've entrusted your life to Christ, you're not.
You're not. Anything the world says or your past says
or the enemy says it, it is you are dead
to sin like you.
You don't have to have its authority anymore.
You don't have to let it reign in your life anymore.
That's you're dead to it.
If you're dead to something, it has no power.
You are dead to sin. That's true of you.
And you are alive to God.
Now, just think of the blessing that is
the God of the universe.
You have a living relationship with him.
You are not enslaved to sin. You're alive.
You can walk with him and live out a life for him.
Like that is a privilege
because of what Christ has done for you.
Amazing grace. You have a new identity.
And the more you rest in that identity,
the more the second result will come about.
It's that Christ not only gives you a new identity,
he gives you a new life, a whole new life,
dead to sin, alive to God.
And like verse four said, just
as Christ was raised from the dead, by the glory
of the Father, we too might walk in newness of life
and we might live a new life.
If we're dead to sin alive to God,
that's gonna look a little bit different.
And that was the point of this section.
It's describing what that new life looks like.
So just rest in this that, that you don't have to
continue living in sin anymore if you're dead to it.
If you are dead to sin, it doesn't have any power.
You are freed.
You're not enslaved to it anymore, you're free.
That's the new life that you can live out in Him.
But there's also this, and we often miss this one.
It's what gives you the power to live that new life.
It's that you have the ability
to live in Christ's resurrection power
that you never had before.
The new life comes
because Christ, his life counts for yours.
His death counts for yours,
and his resurrection counts
by giving you new life a new power.
I don't think we ever conceive of that the the same power
that raised Christ from the dead
lives in you Christian man,
that temptation is strong man, that
that sin keeps coming back.
Resurrection power lives in you, Christian, so
that you can say no to temptation so
that you can not go back to those chains
and wrap yourself back up
with your freed from you don't have to anymore.
So you can say it gives you power to say yes,
to loving others sacrificially that you couldn't
before to say yes to worshiping God with your whole heart.
The resurrection power empowers you to stop living
for yourself and live for other people.
That's what he does to give you a new life.
But hear me, that's only possible.
That kind of life only comes if you are resting in Christ's
victory over sin
and death for you, not by mustering up strength
and going to do it better today than you did yesterday.
It's that you've placed your faith in him
and say, I got nothing.
Jesus. I need you in every way.
And so that's the call today.
Turn to him today
and listen this, this is what he wants to remind you of
through this is
that was based on nothing you could have ever done.
And it's not hindered by anything you have done.
It's because he loves you.
He did all of this even though you're his enemy,
because he loves you.
And so run to him in that love.
Run back to him if you need
to run to him for the first time.
Even if you feel distant,
You feel dry, you feel dead today,
Christ can bring dead parts of you back to life.
So run home, run to this
good Father.
I'm gonna invite the worship leaders to come out now,
and we're gonna continue in the spirit of God's word
as we reflect today.
And I just want you to bow your heads just to kind
of focus a little bit, if you would,
and just reflect and ask questions and think and pray
and respond to the Lord as he would lead us right now.
So again, maybe you're here
and you're just like, well, I didn't, I didn't want to come.
Maybe God, maybe God showed you something today.
You don't know the answers, you don't have all the things
figured out, but, but just in your heart, say,
God, what do you, what do you want from what?
What do you want for me? What do you want from me? How?
How do I respond? And, and just ask Him.
He promises to bless those who seek him.
Or maybe you feel like, man, I'm so far from God right now.
And, and just, man, I hit reset trying
to come back today at Easter.
And Jesus told a great parable about a,
a son who'd run away for a long time and wasted his life.
And the father was there
celebrating his return.